there are many global crypto exchanges
you want to ask the proper questions you
definitely want to spend the time
understanding what you're investing
understanding how your money is kept
safe some of them are more flight by
night kind of operations than others and
that's where the research will pay off
when you go to a new website you should
look for signs of regulation and we've
noticed that very few companies actually
can point out that they're regulated the
usual ways in which you can tell is if
you scroll down to the bottom and look
at some indication that they may be
regulated
look at define print and see where that
entity is regulated some entities may be
regulated in say in the us but then for
non-us clients they may put them in
their bahamas entity where they're not
regulated and therefore they're not
protected in the same way as they are if
they're in the u.s
read customer reviews
it is a little bit tedious but it is
important to to get a sense for what are
other customers saying because that
probably is going to be something you
will face and you want to be aware of it
before it happens to you very often
individuals with notice that they
complain about outages or the difficulty
opening up an account or or very often
the word scam is thrown out in these
comments but is not necessarily true
so you kind of have to read past those
those comments and and try to get to the
bottom line we use trustpilot as a place
that provides that information
but there's other google play stores and
apple store where you can capture some
of these details in the custom review
section you also want to be aware that
sometimes there is some trickery going
on sometimes the the firm evaluated
provides incentives or has a group of
affiliates who are instructed to come
and leave positive reviews we recommend
you look for signs of life activity you
know new products being added new
activities promotions going on that are
dated if you don't see that kind of
activity that could be because this firm
is is dead and has still is up on the
web sphere but but it's it's not really
functioning as it should compare fees
there's a certain mystery around rebates
and volume fees that sometimes it's hard
to keep track of what is my real cost of
trading when in doubt we would recommend
looking at the highest possible fee that
they publish if you put in a big trade
look at what price it showed in the
screen versus what you actually received
and see if there were discrepancies
learn about their history and find out
who were the investors and if they show
those information if you have any doubts
you know safely you know run away from
those firms because there's plenty of
choices for you to pick from we hope and
believe that you should come back to
check out the latest forced ranking of
these exchanges you will find in here a
lot of good information
related to their how much they they
charge their clients whether they're
regulated or not
it will save you a lot of time
you